it's just a fantastic human being
beautiful
hearts are gold
for those who loved her there will never
be enough words to describe Ellie
Edwards
for the first time since she was shot
dead on Christmas Eve her Father Tim
Found the courage and strength to share
some she's the type of person that you
would she would walk in a room
and
you have normal gravitate towards her
because she was always smiling she
beautiful looking she was
to use a hugger she's like me you know
she was just she she's a great hugger so
you but then she would she would do
silly things to
do stupid things to make people laugh
but then she would also have to care
inside of her where she would
she would take the time to make sure you
were all right
but at the age of just 26 this
beautician's life was cut brutally short
her family left inconsolable
she stole the glue
she still keeps us together
uh
and that will always be the case
never change
oh excuse me
what was meant to be a time of
Celebration Tim's family were faced with
utter tragedy
for it to happen on Christmas Eve
how
how disturbing was that as a family it
was not real
too importantly
it was not real
and of course Christmas will never be
the same never
to be no celebration
I mean for me personally Christmas are
getting will never ever be a point of
celebration for me ever
that's that's really sad it is yeah
it is
her killing marked the fifth fatal
shooting in merseyside since August last
year an innocent life lost with
remarkable consequences
there's no winners with gun club there's
nowhere else
you pick up a knife your Future's over
and if everybody else's future around
you is over
and it's dead simple do not pick that
knife up do not pick up that gun because
the minute you do your life is over
and then other people's lives are over
and then it's like a ripple effect and
it is absolutely pointless
solves nothing
cannot be from her death Tim wants
systemic change he hopes a foundation in
her name will bring just that there has
to be a positive
that comes out of
there has to be some kind of
and it's a bit selfish really because
although the future will be used
in Ellie's name
for God
done
that satisfies me
but it has to be that way she can't be
forgotten
and it's likely she won't especially
amongst the hundreds expected to
celebrate Ellie at a funeral next week
you say goodbye to her on Wednesday
how do you think
how do you think that will feel it's
going to be horrible isn't it it's not
going to be nice that's not going to be
good
it was part of the process and let's see
something that has to be done
and then
we move on to the next thing
gotta keep going
to be hard for everyone
know everyone's whole family why the
shape or the amount it's affected so
many people is
um
She'll always be here
she'll never believe me
The Shield level forever